normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government from
uh Naples news comedian Matt R Sparks
controversy with joke in Netflix special
is he performing in Florida well I chose
his local news outlet for a reason
mostly because it just documents the
controversy around comedi met R he had a
Netflix special where he appeared to
mock domestic violence
victims how dare he I really really
don't care that he did and here's the
best part here's from NBC News comedian
Matt R responds to Netflix special
backlash with a link to special needs
helmets he made a post and said it for
everybody who is offended by my joke
here's a link to my apology and when you
clicked it it loaded up I wonder if they
have an image of it I don't think they
do it loaded up a a shopping website for
special needs helmets for people who are
you know differently abled as it were
get him dude I'm just saying shout out
to this comedian but we're starting to
win back seat this is this is the point
about cancel culture I have almost I
would say almost no problem with the
limiting of certain speech I say almost
because we try to be very careful we
want to make sure people have right to
express themselves legitimate
legitimately but you know like people
posting adult content is not legitimate
expression for it's obscene for kids I
think it's fair to say that we're going
to be like no way this dude made a joke
that's it grow up have a nice day laugh
or don't 5 years ago this dude would
have been fired in two seconds look at
was it Shane Gillis was that the
comedian Shane got fired from SNL like a
month of getting hired or something he
did like an accent or something he done
a joke in the past uh like in it like
years ago prior on like an open mic or
something like that where he made fun of
uh Asian Americans he saidit that yeah
he's a great impressionist by the way
and as as as an Asian-American myself I
thought it was hilarious and they fired
him because of it yep correct we're
winning this story shows we're winning
it's not just about the the culture
that's being built it's about a this
dude's 28 and he's got a Netflix special
and he's like don't like my joke I'm
going to double down and insult you even
further well and they I mean Bill bar
had this joke for a long time about you
know of course B Bar Bill Burr sorry I
don't know if Bill bar has ever had J
Bill Burr has had this joke where he
says you know you know they always say
there's never a reason to hit a woman
but you know is that true you could wake
me from a drunken stuper and I could
give you at least 10 or something like
that like that's like alluding to
domestic violence but people laughed I
think he did this joke on some you know
mainstream uh late night show and so
it's interesting how it was something
people tolerated and now they're like
new Young comedian you have to fall in
line or or or stop you know what I mean
it sounds like the crowd is flailing and
they're like w my a my anger that's left
over from five years ago stop and then
he knows Matt R knows if he gets fired
he's good to go like look at Shane
gillis's career is off the charts right
now he's interfacing with Rogan he's
Matt re's already been on Rogan podcast
once oh we we we we have defeated the
the the the woke Beast is is flailing
cancel culture is dying we are
succeeding across the board Hollywood is
failing cable network news is failing
the corporate press is struggling Elon
Musk has launched this nuclear lawsuit
against Media Matters Trump truth social
has just sued 20 news organizations the
amount of Victories and the expansion of
uh of our efforts is just so tremendous
right now ladies and gentlemen you got a
lot to be thankful for this thursdayth
stay concerned because it's like they
have the power and I say they kind of
vaguely but to to turn off your money so
the whole system is is rigged up so that
Visa these central banks can shut off
your access to a bank account and no
more US dollars for you that's like
their atom bomb in the pocket so we
don't want to celebrate like we've won a
war or any kind of long-standing I mean
I I think cryptocurrency is fascinating
that we have other Bitcoin particularly
Bitcoin I mean I like a lot I like a lot
of just the idea of being able to you
Bitcoin a bit of a Bitcoin Maxi yeah a
lot of my friends are too and they're
like bitcoin's up I started in Bitcoin
2013 then bought bought in and then we
made a documentary film called life on
bitcoin where this married couple you
can run it on Amazon and stuff but it's
this do this couple lives on bitcoin for
90 days their first 90 days of their
marriage only Bitcoin in 2013 then we
got into ethereum and other Litecoin
Litecoin and all the other coins and I
was like I was thinking about it like a
technology where I was like number two
is Facebook or number Google came after
Microsoft Etc so the better technology
is going to win and then by couple years
ago maybe a few years ago it I started
thinking about it more like an economist
where I'm thinking about hard money and
what it actually means and what Bitcoin
does well is money that is the one thing
it does well and it does it better than
any of the other other
cryptocurrencies Bitcoin is the money
it's the best at it well and I switched
back and I and we can take a look look
at El Salvador yes that's right and it's
just like booming booming booming
booming it's amazing I'm just I'm just
bu Kelly brought us down for sound of
freedom and did like he's the first
American country to and he screened it
dude he knows what's up that dude's
amazing and uh here's here's a crazy
story for you guys you're going to love
this one there was a a a an illegal
immigrant in the United States who
applied for Asylum claiming that he was
facing persecution in his home country
his home country was El Salvador the
persecution he was a g member that was
going to go to jail so he comes to the
US and get this they release him and
then later we're like wait wait wait
wait what was the persecution he was oh
he's a gang member wanted for crimes
okay we got to arrest him now that's how
crazy things are up here that a guy was
like they're going to arrest me for my a
group affiliation what's your group I
I'm a gang member well the operation was
like okay that makes sense you are a
press like that they didn't even either
they didn't ask or they asked them were
like that does seem hard I wouldn't want
to go to jail either into the US with
you
it's going to be so great Thanksgiving
you know all everybody who's aligned
with freedom meritocracy anti-woke
you're going to be sitting there with
with a smile on your face as your woke
relatives are just grumbling and angry
Biden's losing Hollywood's crumbling
they're losing money and you can just be
like I don't even need to argue with you
we're we're we're on we're on the cusp
of Victory here you guys ever take do
you take Bitcoin for Angel Studios as
currency or is that too much reserve of
Bitcoin yeah and done and we have a
reserve and we've also done Bitcoin
tipping with Tuttle twins there's a
whole episode on on um on bitcoin one of
our rounds we took on a $10 million
chunk of Bitcoin as a reserve for the
company yeah just kind of a backup you
just bought it just just switched it
cash into bitco a fund invested in Angel
and we said we'll take your investment
we'll sell stock for Bitcoin how
long it's been a while yeah a like 100
million or something no not that long
it's still in the the same I mean
bitcoin's up to what like 36 right now
37 today 37 it's just going up I mean
now that um what's his name Javier Malay
got elected in Argentina is talking
about switching them over to bitcoin
well yeah he's first going to go to the
dollar and then his Bitcoin yeah dollar
he's going to do the same thing as Buel
those guys are yeah they're buds I guess
Bull's coming down there to hang out
with him like for the inauguration
bolaro is going to be there yo dude that
is so I mean come on how how are people
how could anyone be pessimistic right
now this is just so amazing I mean
especially with all the stuff you guys
are doing I'm just like m i I'm I'm a
fan of that guy he's oh yeah a he's bold
a I think there were a lot of Americans
he won over you know the day after his
election because they watched him on
pretending no that he was going to do
something different yeah there was a
three I think it was a three person
election and then he and one of the
others got the runoff and and the other
the third person all they all voted
essentially we're all just going to vote
for um La he I guess they announced uh
within 21 days they will end the
ministry of diversity gender and
inclusivity or whatever he's like and
there was some tweet that was like so
you there's illegal to have a gender now
in Argentina it's like no it's illegal
to be a terrible bureaucracy that ruins
people's lives it's crazy I know it's
not even illegal it's just shutting down
a department yeah how dare like the
department has to exist something
exactly getting rid of a department
doesn't mean you don't like the thing
that the department is named sometimes
the name isn't even accurate I want get
rid of the Department of Education but
that doesn't mean I don't believe in
education right look at look at Public
Square you want everyone to be
illiterate you're admitting it here now
you guys like Public Square put out a
statement about their revenue they're
making millions they're expanding they
launched their uh e-commerce officially
I think I think it's officially launched
right the e-commerce on Public Square
I'm just looking at this this year has
been absolutely fantastic you know the
2010s were crazy let me stress you could
not say on Twitter men aren't women they
would ban you for
that absolutely crazy look how far we
look how far we've gone and it's cool
because we do get on to all kinds of
people for saying you know the
Republicans don't do anything or like
local people just focus on National
politics they don't change anything in
our communities and I do think you're
starting to see the the results of
people taking initiative and especially
in the case of Public Square seeing
something that was needed and and
creating it and I think you guys are
similar with the work that you do yeah I
don't know if they take crypto yet
Public Square that's going to be
interesting when that happens would when
you take if you took Bitcoin like to
watch a movie I could pay you on bitcoin
would there be like a tax hell Unleashed
upon the company for taking Bitcoin as
payment or is it past that now or you
can like take it convert it to cash the
US treats it as capital gains tax um
which makes it more and they just made a
a new change to where accountants can
handle uh Bitcoin on their balance sheet
a lot easier which is going to help
companies going to make a big difference
companies that have huge cash res
reserves where we're seeing inflation
like I don't know if you guys been to
the grocery store lately but things are
getting freaking expensive insane and uh
you know I I I it's shocking and I'm I'm
not in the lower income brackets and I'm
just can't believe how expensive it is
and so our reserves our cash reserves as
companies are losing value the longer
they sit so the more cash you have and
so there's going to be a lot more
companies coming in and saying we're
going to put a huge chunk of our
reserves in Bitcoin dude I I mentioned
this the other day we went to Weiss I I
buy these salami packs we usually have a
bunch of them downstairs for everybody
to eat they're $12 a pack now and it's
just it's just like actually that breaks
my heart more than almost anything else
has seen food prices go up cuz I I know
like we grew up in a family with nine
kids in Idaho and it was like a tiny
income like $113,000 a year we came from
the very lowest tier and it breaks my
heart to see people who have been saved
and working their whole lives just like
taking huge steps back because it's
theft it's theft through inflation yeah
the CEO you go the CEO of strike just
said that uh the the US needs to um got
to refinance refinance their debt about
10 trillion 10 trillion over the next 18
to 24 months wow and he says in terms of
scale that's 3x the scale of covid so if
covid generated the kind of inflation we
just saw
you refinancing that debt is going to
generate I'm not going to give anybody
Financial advice or anything so don't
take this advice but if if Argentina
does a a fast shift into Bitcoin like El
Salvador did Argentina is much larger
much wealthier it's a huge Bitcoin is
going to jump in value two or three
times I could only imagine you said it
was the CEO of strike strike what's
strike it's a it's a Bitcoin technology
you can you can just you get a strike
app it's like PayPal but you just buy
Bitcoin and you can actually set it up
to buy Bitcoin every hour thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 pm and become a
member over at timcast.net